all right this morning air travelers
face a new level of attention at airport
airport checkpoints the TSA will now
inspect passengers carry-on bags for
powdered material that is anything from
cosmetic to drink mixes Kris Van Cleave
is a Newark Liberty International
Airport that's just outside New York
City Chris good morning good morning
beginning today when you come to the
airport checkpoints you're going to
start to hear TSA officers asking you to
take larger containers of powder out of
your bags things above 350 milliliters
that's about equivalent to a can of coke
and it's going to be just the same way
you do your laptop or powders and gels
they want to give that secondary
screening so they can look closer at
those items now the TSA is checking a
range of items like powder cosmetics
baby powders and drink mixes even
protein powder at this point passengers
will be encouraged but typically not
required to pack those items in to their
checked bags that's really the
preference here the TSA would like to
see you check them not carry them on now
similar to food food items officers may
also recommend even pulling smaller
containers of powder out of your bag
four separate screening the new
regulations are meant to reduce the
chances explosive material or
debilitating agent like pepper spray can
get on board an airplane but also those
powders can look like explosive material
on an x-ray and that can lead to
extended bag searches which slows the
line down so bottom line you're gonna
start hearing language the TSA and
Airlines would prefer you to check large
containers of powder more than 350
milliliters you'll still be able to
carry them on if you really need to have
it with you but you're gonna need to
take it out of your carry-on bag and
these rules only apply in the standard
lanes not in the pre-check lanes John
Chris thanks